M
CONTEMPLATE POSSIBLE CRIMINAL
CHARGES FOR TRUMP AND HIS
ASSOCIATES.
>> PAULA REED, STICK AROUND.
READING THE TRANSCRIPT OF THE
TESTIMONY OF FORMER WHITE HOUSE
AIDE CASSIDY HUTCHINSON PROVIDES
FASCINATING INSIGHTS INTO TWO
IMPORTANT PARTS OF THE TRUMP
INSURRECTION INVESTIGATION.
ONE IS CASSIDY HUTCHINSON'S
TRANSFORMATION FROM LOYAL MAGA
FOOT SOLDIER TO WHISTLEBLOWER.
DURING HER INTERVIEW WITH THE
COMMITTEE ON FEBRUARY 23rd, SHE
WAS REPEATEDLY ASKED ABOUT THE
STORY SHE HAD HEARD ABOUT TRUMP
IN THE PRESIDENTIAL SUV ON
JANUARY 6th DEMANDING HE BE
TAKEN TO THE CAPITOL.
HUTCHINSON, AT THE ADVICE OF HER
LAWYER, CONTINUALLY TELLS THE
COMMITTEE SHE CANNOT RECALL ANY
DETAILS ABOUT THAT, EVEN THOUGH
SHE CAN.
QUOTE, I FELT THIS MORAL
STRUGGLE, SHE LATER ADMITTED.
I WAS TRYING SO HARD TO BE LOYAL
TO THE PRESIDENT AND TO BE LOYAL
TO HER FORMER BOSS, WHITE HOUSE
CHIEF OF STAFF MARK MEADOWS, AND
TO BE LOYAL TO THE TRUMP WHITE
HOUSE, BUT IN THE BACK OF MY
MIND, TOO, I JUST KEPT THINKING,
LIKE, THIS IS WRONG, I DON'T
LIKE WHO I'M BEING RIGHT NOW,
UNQUOTE.
IN APRIL, CASSIDY HUTCHINSON
READS A LEGAL BRIEF FILED BY THE
COMMITTEE AND SEES EXCERPTS OF
THAT FEBRUARY TESTIMONY, QUOTE,
I KEPT READING HOW I WAS
RESPONDING TO QUESTIONS AND THE
I DON'T RECALLS AND DANCING
AROUND MY RESPONSES, COMPLETELY
HEDGING FOR TRUMP AND MARK
MEADOWS, WHERE I WAS STICKING UP
FOR THEM AND SAYING ESSENTIALLY
WHAT THEY DID REALLY WASN'T THAT
BAD.
I JUST HAD A MENTAL BREAKDOWN
AFTER THAT BECAUSE I WAS
DISAPPOINTED IN MYSELF.
I WAS FRUSTRATED WITH MYSELF.
TO BE BLUNT, I WAS KIND OF
DISGUSTED WITH MYSELF.
I BECAME SOMEBODY I NEVER
THOUGHT THAT I WOULD BECOME, AND
IT WAS HARD TO COME TO TERMS
WITH THEN, IT'S HARD TO LOOK
BACK ON NOW, UNQUOTE.
CASSIDY HUTCHINSON'S
TRANSFORMATION FROM MAGA FOOT
SOLDIER TO COURAGEOUS
WHISTLEBLOWER IS PART OF HISTORY
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
FIRMLY BELIEVE WITHOUT HER
TESTIMONY WE WOULD NOT HAVE
HEARD FROM SO MANY OTHERS WHO
ULTIMATELY PROVIDED VALUABLE
FACTS, INCLUDING FORMER WHITE
HOUSE COUNSEL PAT CIPOLLONE.
THE SECOND MAJOR .1 CAN GLEAN
FROM CASSIDY HUTCHINSON'S
DESCRIPTION OF HER EXPERIENCE
COULD PROVIDE INSIGHTS INTO WHY
SO MANY OTHERS IN THE TRUMP
ORBIT CONTINUED TO SAY I DON'T
RECALL WHEN THEY ASSUREDLY DID.
SHE SOUGHT LEGAL HELP FROM TRUMP
WORLD AND SHE GOT IT.
BUT JUST WHO WAS HER LAWYER
SEEKING TO PROTECT?
QUOTE, WOULD YOU MIND LETTING ME
KNOW WHERE THE FUNDING FOR THIS
IS COMING FROM, SHE ASKS HIM,
ACCORDING TO HER TESTIMONY.
WE'RE NOT TELLING PEOPLE WHERE
FUNDING IS COMING FROM RIGHT
NOW.
DON'T WORRY, WE'RE TAKING CARE
OF YOU, HE RESPONDS.
THEN LATER PREPARING FOR HER
TESTIMONY IN NOVEMBER OF 2021,
CASSIDY HUTCHINSON ASKS, QUOTE,
COULD WE PRINT OFF A CALENDAR
REALLY QUICK, I WANT TO MAKE
SURE I'M GETTING THE DATES RIGHT
WITH THESE THINGS.
HE GOES, NO, NO, NO.
HE SAYS, WE'RE GOING TO DOWNPLAY
YOUR ROLE.
YOU WERE A SECRETARY.
YOU HAD AN ADMINISTRATIVE ROLE.
THE LESS YOU REMEMBER, THE
BETTER.
SHE TELLS HIM, I HAD THIS
CONVERSATION WITH DEPUTY WHITE
HOUSE CHIEF OF STAFF TONY ORNATO
WHEN WE GOT BACK FROM THE RALLY
THAT DAY AND HE TOLD ME THE
PRESIDENT TRIED TO WRAP HIS
HANDS AROUND BOBBY ENGEL'S NECK
AND STRANGLE HIM BECAUSE ENGEL
WOULDN'T TAKE HIM TO THE
CAPITOL.
HE TELLS HER, SHE DOESN'T NEED
TO GO THERE OR SHARE IT WITH THE
COMMITTEE.
HUTCHINSON TRIED TO GET CLARITY,
WHAT'S THE LINE THAT I DRAW
HERE.
HER LAWYER'S RESPONSE, QUOTE,
LOOK, THE GOAL WITH YOU IS TO
GET YOU IN AND OUT.
KEEP YOUR ANSWERS SHORT, SWEET
AND SIMPLE.
THE LESS THE COMMITTEE THINKS
YOU KNOW, THE BETTER.
IT'S GOING TO BE PAINLESS AND
THEN YOU'RE GOING TO BE TAKEN
CARE OF, UNQUOTE.
CASSIDY HUTCHINSON SAYS, QUOTE,
HE SPECIFICALLY TOLD ME I DON'T
WANT YOU TO PURGER YOURSELF, BUT
I DON'T RECALL ISN'T PERJURY,
UNQUOTE.
KEEP IN MIND, ALL THIS TIME, HE
IS HELPING TO SET HER UP ON JOB
INTERVIEWS.
HE SAYS, QUOTE, WE'RE GOING TO
GET YOU A GOOD JOB IN TRUMP
WORLD.
YOU DON'T NEED TO APPLY AT OTHER
PLACES, WE WANT TO KEEP YOU IN
THE FAMILY.
SO THE FREE LEGAL REPRESENTATION
AND JOB OPPORTUNITIES ARE WHAT
SHE'S GETTING, AND WHAT SHE'S
GIVING IS ASSISTANCE IN A
COVER-UP.
IN HER FIRST VERY INTERVIEW WITH
THE COMMITTEE IN FEBRUARY, SHE'S
ASKED MULTIPLE TIMES ABOUT THAT
INCIDENT IN THE SUV, WHICH SHE
SAYS AT THE TIME SHE NEVER HEARD
ANYTHING ABOUT.
BUT THEN DURING A BREAK SHE
TELLS HER ATTORNEY, STEPHEN, I'M
EFFED.
HE RESPONDS, DON'T FREAK OUT,
YOU'RE FINE.
SHE INSISTS, NO, I'M EFFED, I
JUST LIED.
HE SAYS, YOU DIDN'T LIE.
NO, STEPHEN, DO YOU KNOW HOW
MANY TIMES SHE JUST ASKED ME
THAT QUESTION, I JUST LIED.
HE SAYS, THEY DON'T KNOW WHAT
YOU KNOW, CASSIDY.
THEY DON'T KNOW WHAT YOU CAN
RECALL SOME OF THESE THINGS, SO
YOU SAYING I DON'T RECALL IS AN
ENTIRELY ACCEPTABLE RESPONSE TO
THIS, UNQUOTE.
AND THE FEAR OF WHAT WOULD
HAPPEN TO HER IF SHE DID NOT
TAKE HIS ADVICE WAS POTENT, SHE
SAYS IN HER TESTIMONY.
QUOTE, IT WAS ALMOST LIKE I FELT
LIKE I HAD TRUMP LOOKING OVER MY
SHOULDER BECAUSE I KNEW IN SOME
FASHION IT WOULD GET BACK TO HIM
IF I SAID ANYTHING THAT HE WOULD
FIND DISLOYAL, AND THE PROSPECT
OF THAT GENUINELY SCARED ME.
SHE TESTIFIES, I HAD SEEN HOW
VICIOUS THEY CAN BE, THE LEVEL
THEY'LL GO TO TO TEAR SOMEBODY
ELSE DOWN.
AND WHY WOULD SHE FEEL LIKE
TRUMP WAS LOOKING OVER HER
SHOULDER?
WELL, SHE QUOTES THE ATTORNEY
TELLING HER, QUOTE, THE BOSS
DOES READ TRANSCRIPTS AND WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE WHATEVER HE'S
READING ISN'T GOING TO PUT YOU
IN A BAD SITUATION.
I MEAN, IT ALL SOUNDS LIKE A MOB
MOVIE.
BEFORE HER SECOND INTERVIEW, SHE
GETS A CALL FROM AN AIDE TO MARK
MEADOWS, WHO SHE SAYS SAID
SOMETHING TO THE EFFECT OF MARK
WANTS ME TO LET YOU KNOW HE
KNOWS YOU'RE LOYAL AND YOU'RE
GOING TO DO THE RIGHT THING
TOMORROW AND YOU'RE GOING TO
PROTECT HIM AND THE BOSS.
HE KNOWS WE'RE ALL ON THE SAME
TEAM, WE'RE ALL A FAMILY,
UNQUOTE.
HUTCHINSON TESTIFIED THAT SHE
TOLD HER MOM, I'M EFFED, I'M
COMPLETELY INDEBTED TO THESE
PEOPLE AND THEY WILL RUIN MY
LIFE, MOM, IF I DON'T DO WHAT
THEY WANT ME TO DO, UNQUOTE.
THE FINAL STRAW FOR CASSIDY
HUTCHINSON COMES WHEN HE ADVICES
HER TO STOP COOPERATING WITH THE
COMMITTEE.
QUOTE, THERE'S A SMALL ELEMENT
OF RISK TO REFUSING TO
COOPERATE, HE SAYS.
SHE TELLS HER LAWYER, I DON'T
WANT TO GAMBLE WITH BEING HELD
IN CONTEMPT OF CONGRESS.
IF THEY PROSECUTE ME, I COULD
THEORETICALLY GO TO PRISON.
HE SAID, JUST KEEP GIVING IT
SOME THOUGHT, WE REALLY THINK
THIS IS WHAT'S BEST FOR YOU.
THIS NEEDS TO END AT SOME POINT
AND I THINK IT NEEDS TO END NOW.
AND HUTCHINSON EXPLAINS IT WAS
AT THIS MOMENT, I THOUGHT, THIS
DOES NEED TO END NOW, THIS BEING
OUR ATTORNEY-CLIENT
RELATIONSHIP, UNQUOTE.
SO WHEN OTHER TRANSCRIPTS ARE
RELEASED FROM OTHER WITNESSES
AND YOU SEE HOW MANY I DON'T
RECALLS HAVE BEEN OFFERED, KEEP
ALL OF THIS IN MIND.
WE SHOULD NOTE THAT IN A
STATEMENT PASSINTINO SAYS HE
QUOTED HER HONORABLY, ETHICALLY
AND CONSISTENT WITH HER SOLE
INTERESTS AS SHE COMMUNICATED
THEM TO ME, UNQUOTE.
OUR TEAM HERE AT CNN HAS BEEN
WORKING ITS WAY THROUGH THIS 845
PAGE REPORT.
LET'S DISCUSS SOME OF THE KEY
TAKEAWAYS AND THE PRESSURE
CAMPAIGN ON STAR WITNESS CASSIDY
HUTCHINSON.
AND, EVAN, THIS CONVERSATION SHE
RECALLS WITH HER FIRST ATTORNEY,
IS IT EVIDENCE OF INDUCING
PERJURY TO SAY I DON'T RECALL
EVEN IF YOU DO?
>> IT DOES SOUND LIKE IT.
THAT'S ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
CASSIDY HUTCHINSON LIKELY WOULD
HAVE TALKED ABOUT WITH THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT WHEN SHE MET
WITH THEM FOR AN INTERVIEW.
AND HER TESTIMONY GOES BEYOND
JUST HIM.
WHAT YOU'RE HEARING THERE IS A
WIDER EFFORT, REALLY, TO TRY TO
KEEP HER FROM HELPING THIS
COMMITTEE GET TO THE BOTTOM OF
WHAT THEY WERE TRYING TO GET TO
THE BOTTOM OF.
AND THAT INCLUDES MARK MEADOWS.
IF MARK MEADOWS IS PASSING ON
MESSAGES SAYING, I KNOW TOMORROW
IS GOING TO GO WELL FOR YOU,
MAKE SURE YOU STAY ON THE TEAM,
THERE ARE WAYS FOR PROSECUTORS
TO GET AT EXACTLY WHAT WAS GOING
ON HERE, IF THERE WAS A WIDER
CONSPIRACY TO TRY TO MAKE SURE
SHE LIED TO THE COMMITTEE.
THOSE ARE CRIMES.
>> AND, KAITLYN, THE REPORT
ALLEGES THAT TRUMP, PERSONALLY,
QUOTE, OVERSAW THE SCHEME WITH
FAKE ELECTORS IN SEVEN STATES HE
LOST DESPITE CONCERNS FROM HIS
ATTORNEYS, EXPRESSED CONCERNS
THAT DOING SO WOULD BE AGAINST
THE LAW.
WHAT'S THE SIGNIFICANCE OF THIS?
>> JAKE, ONE OF THE THINGS YOU
SEE IN THAT EPISODE, AS WELL AS
THE CASSIDY HUTCHINSON
DOCUMENTATION WE HAVE NOW, IS
THERE ARE SO MANY PEOPLE THAT
WITNESSED WHAT WAS GOING ON AND
SO MANY PEOPLE THAT WERE IN
TOUCH WITH THE VERY SENIOR
PEOPLE AROUND DONALD TRUMP,
PEOPLE LIKE RUDY GIULIANI.
THERE'S A MAN NAMED KEN
CHEESEBOROUGH WHO WAS WORKING AS
A LAWYER FOR THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN.
AND WHAT HAPPENS WHEN THE
COMMITTEE TALKS TO THOSE
HUNDREDS OF PEOPLE RELATED TO
THE FAKE ELECTORS, THEY'RE
GETTING STORIES WHERE IT'S NOT
CLEAR WHO HAS INTENT, WHO IS
KNOWINGLY, WILLFULLY, TRYING TO
SUBMIT THESE FAKE DOCUMENTS.
YOU KNOW WHO DOES KNOW AND WHO
IS KNOWINGLY TAKING PART IN IT?
IT IS THE PEOPLE THAT ARE
ORCHESTRATING IT, AND THOSE ARE
PEOPLE THAT ARE TALKING TO
DONALD TRUMP, NOT JUST ABOUT THE
USE OF ELECTORS IN THOSE STATES,
BUT HOW THAT FITS INTO THE
BROADER PLAN TO TRY AND GET MIKE
PENCE TO STOP THE TRANSFER OF
POWER.
>> PAULA, TRUMP HAS REPEATEDLY
CLAIMED HE WAS RELYING ON THE
ADVICE OF HIS ATTORNEYS IN HIS
ATTACKS ON THE ELECTION.
THE REPORT MAKES IT PRETTY CLEAR
THAT A LOT OF ATTORNEYS WERE NOT
GIVING HIM BAD ADVICE.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
AND THEY ARGUED THIS WAS
PREMEDITATED.
THIS WAS ALWAYS THE PLAN.
THEY PRESENT NEW EVIDENCE,
EMAILS FROM A CONSERVATIVE GROUP
URGING TRUMP TO REBUT THE
ELECTION IF HE LOST.
THEY ARE ALSO PRESENTING NEW
EVIDENCE THAT THE WHITE HOUSE
WAS IN TOUCH WITH JOHN EASTMAN,
FOR EXAMPLE, WHILE HE WAS
DRAFTING HIS INFAMOUS MEMO ABOUT
HOW PENCE COULD TRY TO BLOCK THE
COUNTING OF ELECTORAL VOTES.
WE SAW ON MONDAY THEY PRESENTED
MULTIPLE CLIPS FROM INTERVIEWS
OF WHITE HOUSE ADVISERS TELLING
HIM, YOU DIDN'T LOSE.
THEY CAN POINT TO THESE OTHER
CLIPS.
THEN THEY USED ANECDOTES LIKE
HIM CALLING SIDNEY POWELL CRAZY
WHEN IT COMES TO ALLEGATIONS
ABOUT FOREIGN INTERFERENCE